like a million dollars let that rest
because the flavor will be 10 times more
exciting answers rested the key to
pulling all the different elements of
your Christmas dinner together on the
plate is the gravy my recipe for turkey
gravy made with cider and walnuts has a
wonderful aptly nutty flavor which
beautifully complements the turkey meat
and fruity pork stuffing as that turkeys
resting I want to make the most amazing
gravy when I say amazing I really do
mean amazing drain the excess fat from
the roasting tray and put it back on the
heat then remove the bacon from the top
of the turkey and the roasted onions
from the cavity look at them my god they
smell amazing finally take out the
roasted lemon first of all cut up the
bacon lovely bacon into the tray yeah
Chris potatoes
that's the start I like gravy the onion
look at it beautiful doesn't get any
better than that chop that up onion and
bacon in that smells incredible when I
first got the chance to cook Christmas
lunch for the chefs in Paris they taught
me one crucial thing I was only 21 at
the time and they made me rest the
turkey as long as I cooked it so I
cooked it for three hours and I rested
it for three hours what a difference
incredible next chopped up the roasted
lemon and add to the tray put in a
couple of sprigs of rosemary to give it
a lovely aromatic punch and fry then add
3 chopped tomatoes which helps thicken
the gravy and give it a lovely fresh
taste
now it's time to really get the turkey
flavor into the gravy snap off the wing
take a whole little trimmings all these
little bits here and downs your gravy
these are the bits we know he shoots
everyone throws them away off there a
little baby there
take him off I want that bad flavor
delicious pie that off this smells
incredible
next pour in the dry cider this adds a
lovely subtle apple flavor that really
lives the taste of the turkey meat
as the cider starts to reduce pouring
the delicious resting juices from the
roasted turkey Wow
there you go the most amazing flavor
when the liquid has reduced by half
Chris the vegetables and the turkey
pieces with a masher to extract the
maximum amount of flavor and basically
what's happening now is that we're
giving the gravy a little bit of body
pour in the chicken stock and reduce
again
now not taste Wow we just closed your
eyes there Wow
it uses flavor and Turkey now sip it use
the back of the ladle to push it through
the sieve extracting every last drop of
flavor pop in a sprig of rosemary and
leave to infuse ready for the finishing
touch
simply add crushed walnuts to the bottom
of the gravy boat and ladle in the hot
gravy